i just i don't know how someone could
actually do something like this i think
we really need to ask the question as
well how could something like this
happen how could somebody do something
so evil this is rep ronnie jackson of
texas and he got the memo on what he
needs to say from his puppet masters
when i grew up things were different you
know there was a focus on family and
community and church and i think that
you know we knew each other want me to
prove it what's changed is the culture
the nuclear families collapsing before
our eyes church attendance is an
all-time low
kids brains are being warped by social
media
and we forced our kids into lockdowns
because you see from members of congress
to fox news hosts it's the same
blueprint being pounded down the throats
of conservatives isolating them from
socializing with each other and pushing
them deeper into video games and wicked
internet sites like 4chan is that what
you're saying like how the extremists in
your base go on those sites clown
behavior our culture has changed over
the last you know 30 or 40 years and and
in in the there's been an attack on
those on those things in particular and
i just think that kids are exposed to
all kinds of horrible stuff nowadays too
i look back and i think about the you
know the horrible stuff that they hear
when they listen to rap music the video
games that they watch they're in
lockdowns because of the guns
you twerp you want teachers to be police
officers and the police officers can't
even stop these mother with these
weapons that's the intent the intent
when they manufacture this stuff is to
make sure that you are not stopped with
the gun
what don't you get our guy tony michaels
puts it well and passionately it's the
old bs line of thinking blame minorities
blame lgbtq
and their community blame rap music
blame a lack of church-goers
no
none of those are the reason you know
what screw you ronnie jackson owned by
the gun lobby for a putrid donation you
soulless spineless as many brain cells
as a bike tire stuck in the mud moronic
sellout are you kidding me the tiresome
act
is what conservatives do over and over
again to deflect blame from one thing
they're gun lobby donors
that's all this is or because a corrupt
individual like ronnie jackson who msnbc
reported texted with the oath keepers on
january 6
or when he blamed omicron
on a dem conspiracy
or that you know he's under
investigation
the usual
gop stuff bill frickin o'reilly pulled
this debunked card in 2015. he said
there is no question the people of faith
are being marginalized by a secular
media and pernicious entertainment the
rap industry for example often glorifies
depraved behavior that sinks into the
minds of some young people the group
that is most likely to reject religion
in 2014 mississippi republican senate
candidate chris mcdaniel seen here with
a damn confederate flag behind him
blamed rising gun violence on a hip-hop
culture that values rap and destruction
of community values more than it does
poetry oh please give me a break
mcdaniel went on to conflate rap music
with failing schools and broken
communities because of course he did
conservative radio host rush limbaugh
did more of these bs tactics hip-hop
hip-hop has done more damage to black
and brown people than than racism in the
last
10 years and of course geraldo rivera
it's the easiest targets for absolutely
anything and everything with these
people these brain dead people uh the
united states is not a bad nation it's a
noble nation and and then you go out
there and you talk to a lot of younger
people and this is what gets me that
your constituency are not exactly
political science phd's okay they blamed
hip-hop in 2007 when nationally
syndicated radio host john gibson
remarked another example of hip-hop
culture bringing murder and mayhem into
the rest of our society no you demonic
plague it's still the ability for
anybody to get a firearm in this country
with
ease
they blame it on covet lockdowns they
blame it on video games they blame it on
kendrick lamar i am reiterating i am
drilling it into your head all they care
about is their donors
all they care about is the gun lobby all
they care about is donations from the
gun lobby all of this is smoke and
mirrors it's bs
all of it is excuses
all they care abouts
is their donors period
or to borrow one of their terms point
blank false equivalencies aside though
there's something far more sinister at
play here hip hop is 40 years old we're
well past the time when you need to
explain the chuck d once called hip-hop
black cnn yet the hip-hop boogeyman is
alive and well and by continuing in any
capacity to equate rapping yes blackness
with pathology donald trump's surrogates
are diving into the same racist muck
that the candidate so gleefully treads
with his birtherism and central park 5bs
and sydney blumenthal dog whistle
appeals